[Music]  snick vial is the new bachelor but has  quite a past in bachelor nation it's not  sure why like why you made a love attack  yes Nick was a finalist on both Andi  Dorfman and Kaitlyn Bristowe seasons of  The Bachelorette and et has andis  reaction to the announcement she tells  us exclusively quote I'm happy for Nick  it's been a long road for him but I  think his intentions are pure and he  genuinely wants to find love I'm excited  for him to get another shot at it and  wish him the best Nick and Andy's  relationship has come up again on this  season of bachelor in paradise with viol  owning what she wrote about him in her  tell-all book  you keep saying for picture-book hike  all i know is on my part is not faking  stuff you wrote about me et also spoke  with Bristow  the former Bachelorette says quote -  everyone deserves to find their person  and we want to wish Nick the best of  luck